mais on va plus loin avec aujourd'hui à
mes côtés hamdam mostafavi rédactrice en
chef à l'express bonjour madame et bruno
daroux pour france24 notre chronique
internationale pour bruno bonjour au fel
aucun des dirigeants du groupe etat
islamique n'est à l'abri c'est le
message envoyé ce jeudi par washington
après abu bakar al-bagdadi il ya deux
ans c'est son remplaçant abou ibrahim al
hashimi al qurashi qui tombe dans les
mêmes circonstances préférant actionné
sa propre charge lors d'une opération
des forces spéciales américaines en
syrie sur laquelle est revenu joe biden
écouter
quand nos soldats se sont rapprochés
capturé ce terroriste
par lâcheté il a décidé de déclencher
une charge explosive une charge qu'il
portait il a ainsi fait exploser tout un
étage de la maison
tuant plusieurs membres de sa famille
comme l'avait fait ses prédécesseurs
alors forcément on est on est tenté par
le jeu des comparaisons hamdam mostafavi
le ton tranche avec celui qu'avait
employé donald trump fin 2019 pour
précisément le prédécesseur d'alcon
racheté à la tête de dèche oui c'est
vrai que trump à l'époque était assez
triomphaliste déjà prêt bail donné quand
même lui même aussi un peu triomphaliste
1 il ya quand même chez eux une
un peu
tendance à penser que le problème se
règle quand on se débarrasse du leader
voilà sa majo de cartes irakiens sont
souvent là le fameux jeu de cartes
irakien souvient d'obama avec ben laden
on sait malheureusement maintenant que
le terrorisme ne se règle pas en
supprimant quelques hommes donc même si
bayonne prend plus de précautions que
trump à l'époque il reste il reste un
peu aveugle sur la réalité de la
situation aujourd'hui à mon sens
situation sur le terrain c'est une perte
pour des journaux dao qu'on disait en
pleine résurgence avec l'assaut contre
la prison d'accès à quai dans une autre
région d'ailleurs de syrie cette fois
c'était le nord-est la semaine dernière
c'est une perte momentanée un évidement
de perdre son chef opérationnel qui
avait été assez discret effectivement
depuis un peu plus de deux ans qui avait
quand même permis à l'organisation état
islamique de bien s'implanter en
afghanistan alors qu'ils avaient quand
même fait des choses et puis il avait
encouragé comme ce qu'on appelle ses
cellules dormantes dans le nord-est de
la syrie à l'ouest de l'irak également
de continuer à être opérationnels 1 les
experts estiment qu'au total il ya quand
même dans ces deux régions environ dix
mille combattants de l'organisation qui
sont de fait opérationnel donc oui
perdre son chef c'est une perte à court
terme mais à moyen et long terme pas
vraiment parce que le plus important
pour des ch et bien c'est le groupe le
chef certes est important mais quand le
chef est tué ils s'y attendent
d'ailleurs c'est pour une charge
explosive parce que ils préfèrent se
faire exploser plutôt que de répondre
aux questions de la justice américaine
en l'occurrence donc ils y sont préparés
et ils savent que si un chef par un
autre sera nommé très vite la mort
promise aux leaders ne dissuade pas les
vocations non au contraire peut-être
même ces mêmes l'esprit de martyrs est
en coeur de toute cette affaire pas tant
que ça et je suis d'accord
ce cher leader avait un cv quand même
discret mais néanmoins efficace c'est en
il serait qui les a quand il a été nommé
entre guillemets il était très peu connu
il a il a un parcours en plus irakiens
ils et elles étaient dans l'armée de
saddam hussein il n'était pas
extrêmement séparément telus dans le
match choc de jesi dit voilà c'est ça et
notamment donc auprès de la minorité
kurde d'irak qui là où il a participé
avec avec virulence 1 au massacre mais
c'est vrai qu'il n'était pas non plus ce
n'est pas une figure de premier plan on
se disait voilà mais il a réussi
discrètement mais certainement à
réimplanter
d'état islamique en syrie en irak à
partir d'afghanistan et la question
c'est aujourd'hui est ce que vraiment en
détruisant la tête on arrive à d
implanter ça on sait qu'il ya quand même
eu il ya deux semaines cette attaque
entreprises ont qui a libéré des
centaines de jihadistes on ne sait même
pas vraiment combien on sait qu'il peut
y avoir d'autres attaques de ce type
planifiée contre des prisons parce que
le but aujourd'hui de l'état islamique
c'est de se reconstituer une force et
pour reconstituer une force il faut
aller rechercher ces combattants c'est
normal et rechercher ses combattants
dans des prisons qui sont surpeuplées
mal gardé ce sont aujourd'hui les kurdes
qui doivent gérer ces prisons des qte
qui sont eux mêmes n'ont soutenu et non
reconnue dans cette région donc il ya un
moment donné les difficultés
s'accumulent et ces difficultés là on le
sait ça s'est déjà produit elles servent
l'état islamique que nous dit le lieu
dans lequel s'est déroulée cette
opération le fait que le dirigeant d'edf
se réfugie dans une zone qu'on pensait
plutôt aux mains de la faction rivale
celles dérivées d'al qaïda ya tahrir al
cham c'est à dire ce gouvernorat d'idlib
sous les bombes russe est peuplée 1 de
réfugiés dans des camps samedi que les
que les chefs de ces groupes djihadistes
même si effectivement la poche d'idlib
elle est plus précisément date mais
plutôt contrôlé par le groupe aux avis
cité le le hts ça veut dire en tout cas
que y compris donc les chefs du groupe
etat islamique préfère se réfugier au
milieu de ces millions de réfugiés
puisqu'on estime qu'il ya 4 millions de
personnes n'ont plus d'un million et
demi de déplacés dans la province
d'idlib qui est donc aux mains de ces
groupes islamistes effectivement
bombardé par l'aviation russe sous
contrôle on va dire quand même aussi de
la turquie il est quand même très
présentes puisque ces frontaliers avec
la turquie ce ne sont pas les les
groupes en nombre qui sont présents dans
cette poche ce sont les chefs parce que
ça leur permet de se mêler évidemment
axé ses dizaines et dizaines de milliers
de réfugiés et du coup ils pensent que
ça rende plus compliqué le fait d'être
repéré par les services de renseignement
notamment américains lesquels américains
vont évidemment où il revendique
d'ailleurs d'ores et déjà un succès
est-ce que ça indique une présence plus
plus fort dans parce qu on se souvient
évidemment que donald trump avait fait
sensation en retirant son soutien euros
aux kurdes du nord de la syrie joe biden
avait amorcé une volte face est ce que
ça cette opération est le témoin d'un
réengagement américain ou est-ce que
c'est comme on dit un one shot je pense
qu'elle s'est même du fait que les
américains ont conscience que la guerre
n'est pas finie là bas ce qui est plutôt
un bon signe puisque en effet ce n'est
pas terminé et tout ce que cette issue
honorable c'est à oui pendant ce temps
en syrie il se passera encore des choses
et on le sait malheureusement ce qui se
passe en syrie a un impact sur nous
voilà des les terroristes qui ont
attaqué ici tout ça c'est voilà c'est ce
sont ce sont des affaires qui sont liés
on peut pas faire comme si c'était très
loin et qui n'avaient pas d'importance
les américains aujourd'hui alors
peut-être à cause aussi du reste du
contexte géopolitique de la russie de la
turquie
encore mais ont conscience qu'ils ne
peuvent pas complètement abandonné la
région justement parce que les seuls en
fait les seules personnes qui sont sur
place et qui en gros défendre un peu
l'esprit démocratique et tu as ce sont
les kurdes qui sont eux-mêmes attaqué
par la turquie eux-mêmes fragilisé et on
est quand même dans ce dans une période
assez assez assez tendu où nos riches
pas tout à fait d'accord je peux tout à
fait d'accord avec vous parce que je
pense qu'en fait on est dans la nouvelle
doctrine stratégique géopolitique de joe
biden quand il a fait le retrait
d'afghanistan qui certes de un produit
opérationnel a été un fiasco mais il a
expliqué en fait il a dit le rôle des
états unis ce n'est plus d'avoir des
centaines des milliers de soldats
américains dans tel ou tel pays la
menace terroriste est mondiale donc il
faut lutter par avec les cyber outils
les drones voir quand c'est nécessaire
des commandos pour les gros poissons en
quelque sorte mais nous ne devons plus
être présents massivement d'ailleurs les
kurdes sont toujours pas très content
quand même du fait que malgré l'élection
de joe biden n'y a pas vraiment de
changement par rapport à la doctrine de
donald trump donc en fait là ce que ce
qui s'est passé là c'était un assassinat
ciblé pour un gros poisson qui a été
réussi mais c'est la mise en oeuvre de
la nouvelle doctrine byden c'est à dire
on n'en voit plus des centaines et des
milliers d'hommes on cible quand on
arrive à repérer avec le renseignement
on cible on élimine et c'est ainsi qu'on
peut lutter selon joe biden de manière
plus globale
face à un terrorisme mondialisé les
forces spéciales américaines jeu mais
qui était déjà à l'oeuvre avec les
britanniques a attaqué la semaine
dernière nous dit-on pour le bal à la
libération il est d'ailleurs selon
certaines sources en fait c'est là
qu'ils auraient réussi à voir
l'information jeu jean paul
conditionnelle sur la localisation de al
qurashi qui aurait permis l'opération de
la nuit dernière en fait il se pose lui
en faiseur de paix redjep tayyip erdogan
en visite à kiev offre sa médaille et
médiation dans la crise entre russes et
ukrainiens écouter
la turquie est prête à prendre part à la
résolution de cette crise entre eux deux
pays amis qui sont ses voisins en mer
noire
j'ai dit au cours des discussions
d'aujourd'hui que nous pourrions
volontiers organiser un sommet entre
dirigeants
ou des discussions au niveau technique
après avoir hébergé pour l'europe une
partie des migrants syrien va-t-il
éviter au continent une guerre aux
conséquences potentiellement
désastreuses cataclysmique hamdam
mostafavi erdogan est dans son rôle
préféré celui de sauveur de l'humanité
mais surtout c'est celui finalement qui
a le moins d'intérêt à skis un conflit
entre l'ukraine et la russie donc
vraiment c'est aussi ses propres
intérêts qu'ils essaient de sauvegarder
puisqu'il est exactement pour le coup un
peu entre le marteau et l'enclume c'est
à dire que il a des intérêts fort ils
ont des liens très forts les lectures
qu'avec avec les ukrainiens il arme en
partie les ukrainiens de drones même si
ça reste non c'est pas non plus avec ça
que les ukrainiens ont repoussé une
armée russe mais bon voilà il ya des
liens et ensuite économiquement d'autres
pas et dépenses il dépend énormément des
russes et ils ne veulent pas se fâcher
avec les russes pour plein de raisons y
compris des raisons dont parlait
précédemment sur les conflits en syrie
et ailleurs donc c'est vrai que
erdogan l'a un peu une occasion unique
de se présenter en faiseurs de paix
marche sur des oeufs parce que ce
vacarme et les ukrainiens 100 par
ailleurs on est finalement afro enfin en
tout cas on a des intérêts divergents
avec la russie sur la libye la syrie le
haut karabagh ou encore on l'a vu le
kazakhstan ça fait quand même beaucoup
pour être
et redonne il assume complètement le
fait d'avoir une relation purement
d'intérêt avec la russie voilà sur
certains sujets ils ont des intérêts
partagés sur d'autres ils ont des
intérêts divergents la géographie fait
qu' ils sont obligés quand même de
composer ensemble et puis aussi ardoines
il joue sa carte à lui qui est quand
même une carte intéressante c'est à dire
qu'il est membre de l'otan et donc en
fait il est un peu on va dire peut-être
un peu comme victor sorbonne qui s'est
rendu à moscou c'est à dire ça fait
partie de ces pays qui sont membres de
l'alliance atlantique donc qui on le
soutient officiellement des états unis
mais qui ont aussi une relation plus
privilégiés avec moscou et qui essayent
évidemment de jouer leur carte parce
qu'il faut bien se rendre compte que
dans tout le grand raout diplomatique la
quelle on est en train d'assister il y à
aussi pour chacun des leaders et ça vaut
pour le premier ministre britannique le
président français le chancelier
allemand celui qui permettra de
débloquer ou de trouver une solution
diplomatique celui qui arrivera à faire
ça évidemment ce sera le jackpot pour
lui on en est là dans un jeu presque
théâtrale
on est dans un jeu de postures on est
quand même dans un jeu de postures
lui-même poutine est pas mal dans la
posture il ay la montre est quand même
pas mal
les fêtes qui voit là il voulait
s'imposer dans l'agent après voilà il
reste quand même des faits on sait que
les américains ont rien enfin là on en
parlait de ont remis des des soldats en
tout cas vers la pologne et ça reste
sérieuses à la menace n'est pas que que
théâtre théâtre de deux mais c'est vrai
qu'on a l'impression que là ça fait
plusieurs semaines qu'on parle de
l'ukraine donc qu'on était dans une
autre phase ou peut-être à nouveau la
diplomatie peut mener à quelque chose
que moscou n'a peut-être pas les mêmes
intérêts est ce que c'est une trêve
olympique ou est-ce que ça va vraiment
se dégonfler c1 c'est un peu ce qu'on se
demande et on a vu l'europe qui cherche
effectivement existé par la voix d
emmanuel macron notamment qui parle
beaucoup au téléphone en ce moment à
bülach il parle beaucoup au téléphone
avec vladimir poutine nommé c'est ça
compte quand même c'est pas c'est pas
qu'une question de théâtres en fête
c'est aussi une question de de
concurrence si vous voulez diplomatiques
entre les uns et les autres chacun joue
de ses armes de ses atouts pour essayer
de parler à vladimir poutine qui lui du
coup est dans une position assez
confortable pour cadrer il est courtisé
après avoir dit que il ne voulait parler
qu'avec les états unis finalement il se
rend compte que pour avancer ses pions
s'il peut utiliser entre guillemets
d'autres puissances comme l'est la
puissance voilà française allemand de
tueur ben pourquoi pas ça brouille un
peu les cartes ça lui permet de gagner
du temps et peut-être pense-t-il de
faire avancer sa cause à lui donc oui il
ya il ya des concurrents c'est une
politique mais je trouve que depuis
quinze jours l'europe quand même réussi
à ré exister quand même dans cette crise
y compris au delà de l'union européenne
d'ailleurs si on pense à aux initiatives
prises également par la grande bretagne
ça va être dur quand même de retirer
sans peut-être cent trente mille hommes
demain après les avoir aligné le long de
la frontière il va falloir qu'ils
trouvent une justification vladimir
poutine non c'est basique il est retiré
n'ont pu immédiatement après il peut les
il trouvera titre aura toujours quelque
chose et quelque chose après est ce que
vraiment ça va si ça se dégonfle ça va
se traduire immédiatement par un retrait
des soldats juste il faut qu'il obtienne
quelque chose quoi voilà il est là elle
a quand même
là je voyais que les états unis ont
quand même fait des propositions 1 ils
disent ils s'engagent à ne pas déployer
alors ils s'engageraient les deux camps
ne pas déployer de moyens militaires
offensif en ukraine comme ça ça met de
côté la question de l'adhésion à l'otan
ou parvient à la finlandisation voilà on
va en tout cas c'est une proposition des
américains moscou serait autorisée à
inspecter certaines infrastructures
militaires qui l'inquiète en europe dont
vous voyez quand même que on progresse
un peu et peut-être comme vladimir
poutine ira bon d'accord si si il ya ça
et sa bombe à broc et finalement ça me
satisfait et du coup bah je retire je
retiens m prenant n'est pas là mais on
sent que ça avance un peu plus
concrètement sur un plan diplomatique
merci bruno daroux merci également à
mohammad mostafavi on va plus loin
c'était sûr donc la présence aujourd'hui
de redjep tayyip erdogan à kiev place à
présent au focus et